this is a Fox News Alert a draft report
by Republican members of the House
Intelligence Committee says that there
is quote no evidence of collusion
coordination or conspiracy between the
Trump campaign and the Russians that's
the result of 14 months of investigation
good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight the new report we just
referred to found no evidence of
collusion it did warn that America was
woefully unprepared to check Russian
meddling efforts and has done little to
improve since then it also blasts our
top intelligence officials for leaking
to the media 150 page report will now be
reviewed by Democrats and intelligence
officials before it is released to the
public
congressman Mike Conaway is a Republican
representing Texas he led the
investigation by House Republicans into
Russia meddling and he joins us in the
studio tonight Congress thanks for
coming on so is the report as definitive
as we just suggested on the question of
pollution pollution it is to her we've
we've interviewed 73 witnesses we've
looked at three hundred plus thousand
documents to try to find what there
might be we've seen some perhaps
meetings that were inappropriate or
ill-advised to have taken we've seen
some chants coincidence where people
bump into each other at various places
but no evidence of collusion between the
Trump campaign and the Russians or the
Clinton campaign and the Russians know
you satisfied that you saw enough
intelligence gathered by our Intel
agencies to make that judgment well we
made the judgment based on our own
investigation of witnesses we've been
aggrieved like I said seventy three
witnesses looking for that thread that
that would lead us to a collusion
conspiracy record nation we ask every
witness that and we've come to we found
no evidence that anything like that was
going on so Adam Schiff today who'd be
the ranking Democrat on the committee
released a statement calling this report
and I'm quoting a tragic milestone yet
another jet he says its short-circuits
an investigation that he implies is just
getting going
well fourteen months is not just getting
going like I said we've done the work we
believe is necessary to answer the four
questions we had a pretty narrow scope
it did not include collusion definitely
a lot of things that the perhaps the
Dems would like to chase down it had
four questions and we have four
questions answered and we think we've
done the relevant
to answer those questions huh so you you
must have learned a lot about the story
more broadly it sounds like you did
after all of that time you say that the
the Intel agencies released their famous
report that the 17 so-called
intelligence agencies saying that the
Putin government favored Trump and
you're saying that's not correct
well first off is three agencies the
salty nation where that's why I said the
talkers I had actually including the
Coast Guard and all the rest John
Podesta what time because he was trying
to pitch that I hear it every night
pretty confident the NRO had no yeah I
got that so the three they did 98
percent of what they did on that I ca we
agree with we had two trained analysts
and two trained professionals go through
that with a fine-toothed comb all of the
underlying documents um thousands of
pages of documents right and and the
piece of our Trump our but the pluton
purported preference for Trump we think
is not supported by the evidence that
was available throughout the entire
process why would they say that what
that's now but we believe that we
disagree with them at that thing started
early December and was finished in
January
coinciding with an attack on the trump
presidency throughout that timeframe by
other issues things going on yes and
this seemed to to underpin that
narrative that somehow you know Putin
had a had more effect on the election
they should have and it's a deal eternal
gee legitimate D legitimate eyes the
Trump residency easy for you to say the
Trump presidency there was a part of
that narrative but the Intel agencies
are taken at face value because as we're
often reminded by Democrats or the final
word on what's true well it sounds
almost like a political statement they
were making well it looks like that but
like said ninety-eight percent of what
they did in the ICA we think is with the
tradecraft
there is tradecraft the social yes
associated with analytics and that they
were that was properly followed but just
on that one piece that Putin's alleged
preference for Trump it was not
supported by the mother I've never been
clear on the underlying questions that
undergird all of this and that would be
the hacking of the DNC servers and of
John Podesta's gmail account and I asked
the ranking Democrat on your committee
Adam Schiff about this and couldn't get
a straight answer are we absolutely
positive that the Russian government was
behind stealing that data
I believe we're as positive as you can
be
and the circumstances where attribution
is very difficult but I'm comfortable
believing that that Russian government
was behind the hackers that did all this
the agency IRA whether the entities were
doing it we're done there were some
behalf of the Russian government if not
on behalf of our directory by so I'm
comfortable making that statement again
you know attribution is very difficult
and in cyber world will this convince
anyone well the past will MSNBC tomorrow
say you know what we've been wrong for
the last never exactly you know when I
throughout this whole timeframe I've
been saying privately because nobody's
ever seen me on TV before tonight to you
guys and earlier that there'll be some
people agree with us that some people
disagree what I want the the report
their standard is sone tell that folks
they Connor we didn't have a thumb of
the scale shift and heaviest on land
scale but as much of the underlying
documentation in there as we possibly
can so that readers can decide for
themselves whether or not we did a
thorough investigation of what we based
our conclusions on then let the American
people make it their own mine
the real issue though is we've got
elections starting right now had the
Texas primary last week we get lecture
tomorrow this is a big deal that we
don't want the Russians or anyone
interfering and appropriately with our
election process and so getting these
conclusions out beginning to have that
conversation with the American people
during this election season for 18 is
really important and that help just get
us to where we are right there yeah
there's a lot we don't know but you've
confirmed what we've suspected all along
which is the collusion narrative was a
lie well if the the Democrats have
additional evidence they're not showing
us that they make reference to over and
over that they do have evidence to that
this drafting process will start in the
morning we'll have a chance to yeah
let's see it we can make up our own
minds congressman thank you for that I
appreciate this overview thanks